The [INAUDIBLE] algorithm has
the so-called five style structure.
That is, encryption and
decryption differ only in key schedule.
That is in decryption,
we apply the same operations
as in encryption, but
only with the key sequence in reverse.
That is, round one of decryption uses
the key of the last round of encryption.
And so on and so forth.
We can take a closer look to verify
that decryption really works by applying
the same operations as an encryption,
and only the key sequence in reverse.
In particular,
we only need to look at the decryption
operations in the last round.
The input to each round, for
example, the input to the first
round of decryption is actually R and
N in reverse order,
meaning the right half is on the left,
and the left half is on the right.
This is due to the swap operation at
the end of the encryption process.
For example, the input to the first
round of decryption would be R16 and
L16, because encryption has 16 rounds.
And here, because we are using the key
sequence in reverse in decryption,
then the key using the first
round of decryption
is the key using the 16th
round of encryption.
Record that we can use algebra to
represent the desk operations.
If you use those algebra expressions,
you will be able to verify that given
this input in the decryption process you
should be able to produce this output.
I'll leave these as a exercise for
you to do at home.
Therefore, after 16 rounds
of decryption process,
the output would be R and
L in plaintext.
In the final swap operation
at the end of the process
would produce the correct plain text
result L and R in the correct order.
And this is how
decryption in this works.